all right and I can't be seeking
backbone from state to state
man you trippin you kid I need to take a
break
noodles chips and Twinkies on my dinner
plate yeah never give you roses because
I wake up late post another base kiss
old NBA
but I've been binging Netflix though so
I'd be straight
it's a boy but I'm always down for Top
Ramen and I'm a hot boy but my
temperature stays solid CDC said I'm an
e6 I'm six guys so that seems straight
so homie I'm Annie a just said oh yeah
that's real you said I've been in the
crib is watching Netflix tested new
friends on me I'm talking but I'm hungry
I'm hungry I'm hungry I'm hungry I'm
home I ran out of the groceries monitor
beeping oh honey water some water fell
on my tummy
[Music]
new rules on my plate I had a step for a
first big a little husband before days
but I'm still balling feel like Charlie
I so like important that God fishing -
hey I'm stalling not gonna die your norm
you can only talk to me if you call it
he shakes china corner
I need the faucet paper for my toilet
[Music]
nicely and coming on again just some
butter
Isis late